enfin prêt à décoller le cirad haut à
saint cyr l'école a proposé aux
adolescents pour la première fois une
activité de construction de planeur les
moniteurs du club d'aéromodélisme des
clayes-sous-bois ont appris aux enfants
à construire leur propre avion
ils sont partis de planches de balsa les
deux baguettes sur sûr on leur a donné
des gabarits qui leur ont permis de
dessiner de couper les pièces ensuite
sur nos sources des indications les
ondes et ont collé avec les ans les en
tenir avec des épingles et quand c'était
ennuyeux quand a été collé il a fallu
lester ces petits avions et maintenant
ils sont prêts à voler des clairement
serra do y ait une meilleure ambiance
que d'habitude et en plus bien ça occupe
ce que j'ai apprécié donc déjà c'est
construire mon premier avion puisque
déjà c'est mon tout premier est aussi
bas ça m'a fait découvrir quelque chose
que je connaissais pas pour clôturer le
stage les enfants ont été invités au
tournoi d'aéromodélisme entre les
meilleurs pilotes de la discipline
clayes-sous-bois